what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so we are covering the Watchmen now
for a lot of you guys who are new to d.c
rebirth The Watchmen is like they're
like the central focal of all this stuff
right like people are looking around and
they're like yeah The Watchmen like I'm
really excited to see what happens with
the Watchmen because we don't really
know what's going on with them
we know the Watchmen are part of DC
rebirth but we don't know how they got
there
we presume that it's because of the
events of Barry Allen during flashpoint
which created the new 52
DC's line wide reboot but we don't know
how far-reaching the events of dr.
Manhattan go we don't know how
far-reaching all this stuff goes all we
know is that the Watchmen are there in
some form or fashion and dr. Manhattan
stole ten years from everybody and
basically everything that we read in the
origin stories of these DC characters
when the new 52 first launched is not
entirely true there's more to their
histories that were simply not aware of
and so the idea here is to basically
cover the original Watchmen story and
the reason behind this is because it
gives people context when fans when they
read forms and people are just like yeah
The Watchmen in the DC Universe
it gives them context it gives people an
understanding as to why everybody is so
excited about the Watchmen themselves
now if you've seen the Watchmen movie
what you'll actually find is that a lot
of the stuff in this comic really goes
hand in hand with the film it was really
a pretty faithful adaptation in terms of
how the characters were to pick did and
so on and so forth at least in the first
little bit of this I mean like any movie
there's certain liberties that are taken
by the directors producers actors so on
and so forth when it comes to adapting
something that came in book form or
comic book form to an actual film but
there'll be enough closeness here that
you'll be able to find some measure of a
recognized ability now the cool thing
about this is that we initially pick up
with the death of the comedian remember
that's one of the first big things that
happens because the Watchmen is nothing
if not a whodunit mystery which is to
say who in the world killed a comedian
that's really the basis behind all this
now of course with these detectives
going through and piecing things
together kind of you know looking at the
evidence at hand indicating there was a
struggle that there was basically a
fight that's something that I hope you
notice here and the movie you basically
saw this flight play out and then the
aftermath with the police investigating
and this you get it's interspersed in
between now of course the indication
here is that the comedian was a man of
such a stature that he's not somebody
easily tappable
comedians Nucky had killed by some
average high school student or some guy
with a gun that's not how that works
when it comes to the Watchmen universe
these stories are a lot more grounded
they're a lot more realistic they're a
lot more tangible
that's why dr. Manhattan is really the
only guy with godlike powers everybody
else for the most part is just your
regular guy they have little things that
set them apart but on the whole they're
really not that different that was the
basis behind this The Watchmen story was
as much a critique on existing
superheroes as it was a comic book story
in and of itself but the idea here is to
ask the question who possibly could have
killed this guy now of course the police
who were investigating these detectives
really just kind of ride it off and say
well maybe it was a couple guys and
maybe he just pissed somebody off and
that's just kind of the way it goes but
notice how it's thrown away it's not
like they say man this is priority
number one we have to figure this out
this again is really harkening back to
the nature of superhero comics if for
example we were to pick up a story where
the Justice League walk into the
watchtower and find Batman dead on the
floor and bleeding well then it would be
this great big huge thing worse like
this is the number one priority for the
Justice League everything stops in this
story it's not that way for the most
part everybody just continues going
about their normal lives
yeah the comedian died and that sucks
but it's because they never really knew
anything about each other they were so
removed they were so isolated again
another hit at the old school comics
that existed out there this idea that
when it came to the original superheroes
that it was just to say really DC's
Justice League there was a time when
none of them knew the other's identities
Superman did not know the flash was
Barry out now Superman didn't know that
Hal Jordan was the Green Lantern they
kept their identities hidden now the
goal was to basically have the Justice
League reveal their identities for the
purpose of creating cohesiveness
familiarity to create some measure of
relatability with regards to to the
watchmen it's not that way these guys
fought as a team sure but they are by no
means friends for the most part some of
them are like me you know a few here and
there but there were really just more
friends of circumstance as opposed to
genuine actual friends now of course
this comes in to the introduction of
Rorschach and for the most part
Rorschach doesn't really say anything in
the beginning of this story which is one
of the cool things about it Rorschach's
really well known in the Watchmen movie
for having these awesome monologues or
like these journal entries as so on a
sofa
he's very similar to Punisher in that
regard now regarding the character of
night owl this is when we start to
switch over to dan dreiberg and Hollis
Mason
now night owl is a concept like Captain
America right you know Captain America
is a title this is basically given to
people anybody who puts on the suit
wears the shield that's Captain America
what this does is it begins to sort of
expand on the Watchmen mythos to a
degree by introducing a group called the
Minutemen now the Watchmen are not
necessarily the first iteration of the
superhero team for the most part the
Watchmen are just kind of the more
recent adaptation of the team but with
regards to going back really in the
earliest days there were the Minutemen
and the Minutemen were again just
regular people who got together and they
got tired of seeing criminals running
rampant they got tired of seeing cops
unable to deal with the various crimes
that were committed and so the idea was
that the Minutemen were literally going
to be vigilantes they were going to be
superheroes or they're gonna be people
who went out and they stopped crime from
happening or punished those who were
criminals but because of the fact that
Hollis Mason was the first Nite Owl and
dan dreiberg picked up the mantle what
this means is there's some sort of
connection between the two of them even
if it's only through the title itself
dan dreiberg is continuing this legacy
created by Hollis Mason and again this
hits at the nature of titles versus
characters who are inherently who they
are
Superman is inherently Superman he was
born as the character Superman you know
he was born with super-strength
SuperSpeed but with someone like Batman
he witnessed his parents being shot in
Crime Alley in Gotham City and then
decided to become a Caped Crusader and
that's how all this stuff really begins
to tie together that's why it works now
of course with dan dreiberg getting back
home he basically runs into Rorschach
and this is again when we started to
figure out a little bit of the things
that were going on behind the scenes
this idea that before this story took
place the Watchmen were legitimate
superhero team the Watchmen carried on
the legacy of the Minutemen The Watchmen
served the purpose of keeping crime
basically curbed within the city of New
York as best they possibly could the
issue with this is that in the 1970s
there was a bill that was passed that
banned superhero activity in the form of
individuals who wore masks as though the
result is that those individuals who
were members of The Watchmen for the
most part didn't want to hand over their
identities and so instead of coming
forward and saying I dan dreiberg em
Nite Owl and I'm going to continue to be
a superhero to be a vigilante he simply
just walked over
and that's where war Shack has this sort
of resentment when it comes to these
characters war Shack is by all standards
of measurement in antihero the idea is
that because there's a bit of resentment
here on behalf of Rorschach with regards
to the fact that dan dreiberg just
doesn't really have any information here
he's not really able to offer any
insight on who it was that killed
comedian but more so than that dreiberg
was one of the guys who just quit and
gave up when superheroes were outlawed
ultimately he ends up moving on now of
course this leads us into the methods
that war Shack uses to gain information
but also the nature of war shock himself
again going into the events before
Watchmen war shock made a name for
himself as a guy who did whatever it
took to figure out what it was and he
needed to know which included beating
out bad guys torturing people he walks
into this bar people immediately know
who he is and they are terrified of him
now a couple of new guys here and there
who were new to the criminal element the
criminal underworld really kind of
offers some sniggering remarks they
really just sort of you know say some
inappropriate things that sort of scoff
him off but those who were in the know
those people who know who were shocked
is are perfectly aware of the fact that
he's not a bear that you poke and prod
and so when this guy starts going around
and mouthing off he immediately gains
the attention of Rorschach Rorschach's
his fingers and tells everybody else
this same fate awaits you if you don't
tell me what I need to know but the
problem with this and really the idea
that's being purported here is that with
enough pain and enough torture people
who have information will reveal that
information and truth this is one of the
big arguments against the concept of
torture if you torture a person for
information don't say whatever they need
to say in order to make the torture stop
so you can't really take this
information with gospel truth but for
the sake of this comic they're just kind
of going with it Alan Moore is just kind
of like hey look these guys don't really
know anything take it for what it's
worth and we'll move on and so again
that's why Rorschach is one of the the
pivotal characters but when it comes to
the Watchmen mythos because he's
literally giving us a tour of all these
different members who were part of the
Watchmen somewhere along the line
Ozymandias the guy who was basically
sitting around and instead of walking
away from the superhero landscape and
giving it all up he embraced it he said
yeah I am Ozymandias and then he turned
around and sort of profiteering it now
the reason why this is also important is
because vibe is considered to be one of
the smartest people on the face of the
earth I believe he's the smartest man
that's out there and the idea here is
that it makes perfect sense but if he
can capitalize
on his own name if he can capitalize by
basically drawing in those who supported
the Watchmen and in turn creating action
figures creating products that people
will in turn buy he can quite literally
build this massive enterprise and want
for nothing for the rest of his life and
that's exactly what he did having the
intelligence to pull it off that's what
makes things so cool now at this point
we switch over to dr. Manhattan and this
is when we get into the idea of the only
guy who's really just that powerful the
only guy who's really just super capable
in terms of whatever it is that he wants
to do now again as this story goes on
we'll start to get a little more about
what it is that his character can do in
terms of what he's capable of the kind
of powers he possesses different things
like that but the idea is that would him
popping up on the scene and basically
saying hey look the comedian is dead the
question now becomes what other members
of the watchmen is this killer hunting
down and so again this is kind of a
weird scenario when it comes to
manhattan because who could possibly
kill him how could a person kill someone
who's effectively God who's literally
bound by the limits of nothingness who's
bound by the limits of infinity now of
course in the midst of this great bq's
discussion with Rorschach talking about
the dangers of you know who it is is
coming after dr. Manhattan digging up
these old skeletons of The Watchmen and
so on of course it in turn upsets you
know miss Jupiter which in turn
dr. Manhattan basically throws him out
and that's really yet but again the idea
here is that this starts to focus on the
disconnect of dr. Manhattan from those
people in his life in this instance is
really him talking to miss Jupiter and
just saying hey look you're gonna go do
your own thing you know you're gonna be
disappointed the fact that I'm not
talking to you you're gonna be
disappointed the fact that I can't give
you the kind of companionship that you
want
you're gonna seek out dan dreiberg
you're gonna go have dinner with him so
tell them I said hey now this is one of
those interesting situations when it
comes to Manhattan because people will
say that dr. Manhattan as a character
who's curious about humanity and truth I
would say dr. Manhattan's a character
who's transcended humanity that's one of
the big points with his character as the
Watchmen goes on eventually he just gets
bored of the petty squabbles of humanity
and it makes sense it's like if you're
the smartest man in the room and you're
hearing people squabble over whether or
not two plus two equals four I mean
you're literally just listening to the
dumbest people in the world argue about
things that don't really matter and so
in response to this his whole idea is to
basically begin the process of walking
away from it all now at the end
we've gotten to the point where he's
basically just working on this sort of
infinite energy that exists out there
this idea that he alongside Adrian Veidt
can begin the process of creating
infinite energy for everyone now again
that's why this whole thing comes into
play because it's really just hey he's
doing this because what else does he
have to do there's really nothing else
out there that keeps him interested that
keeps them entertained it keeps his mind
at work the result of this is that when
a time comes he's gonna bail out because
he's just gonna get tired of working on
all this but of course with miss Jupiter
she basically takes off goes to seed and
dreiberg and of course with the two of
them they basically began just kind of
reliving these old moments and one of
the funny things about this and you'll
recall this from the movie because they
talked about a character named captain
carnage the funny thing about this is
that he was this guy who basically just
like ran around and committed crimes
just so he could get beat up and the
funny thing about this is it again this
hits at this like really basic nature of
heroes and that's kind of the cool thing
here because we'll talk about this in
relation to the old-school DC here in a
second but of course running in a
Rorschach the question you know that
that's asked here is but what ever
happened to captain carnage it's like
well you know he tries it on Rorschach
and he drop him down an elevator shaft
guys got no patience but again this hits
back home to the old-school DC Comics
the best example that I can give and
really the best stories I would suggest
is something called world's greatest
superheroes world greatest superheroes
if you ever read stories you ever you
know looked up Google Images of Alex
Ross art you'll see these stories that
are really really short and it's like
Batman and Superman and I believe Wonder
Woman in the flash I do not believe
there's one on Green Lantern but the
idea here is that world's greatest
superheroes were basically stories about
the 1930s and 1940s superheroes in terms
of the actions that they did but the
nature of Alex Ross art in conjunction
with that storytelling is that it wasn't
meant to depict Superman as this godly
being with incredible power who can pull
planets out of a dying galaxy instead it
was basically designed to humanize
Superman the costume was a fancy
flamboyant or anything like that it was
literally something you'd look like
you'd buy at a costume shop Batman was
the exact same way they were basic they
were simple it was really more like
people wearing costumes as opposed to
these godly beings wearing costumes what
is dead is it created a feeling of
familiarity created this idea that they
are just people and that's what this is
designed
is designed to basically say these
aren't gods they're not these impossibly
powerful beings instead they're just
some folks who got together and wanted
to fight crime
now of course dr. Manhattan's story is a
lot more complex and he served a far
greater purpose in the world did any of
the other members of the Watchmen did
but again I really hope this gives you
guys an idea of what the Watchmen are
about what they really are for the most
part in terms of how they function in
terms of how they come together and this
path that basically sets them on this
this collision course for the ultimate
end of the events that of course will
come to the end of these twelve videos
but without being said guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments
explained to make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]